y'all ready for your next comedian make
some noise come on
this next guy is the newest regular for
kill tony very funny man make some noise
[Applause]
[Music]
live long and prosper
know what you're thinking but i was like
this before the vaccine too
easily autistic
i got the vaccine north i like to call
it western acupuncture
only one needle
[Applause]
really tiny
but uh yeah i'm autistic which is the
worst kind of disease to have this is
the only disease you get diagnosed in a
bar
no one's ever like hey you sound like
you have non-hodgkin's
let's see eager box with this guy he has
cancer
what is this lyme disease you know but
uh it's good to be here with the death
squad show you know i know a lot of guys
listen to rogan so
i just want to know why joe rogan
believes in free speech for everyone
except the guests on his podcast
come to my podcast where millions of
people can listen to
me interrupt you
i would love to be interrupted by joe
father joe
uh but it's good to be here in texas i
am uh
from south korea so i'm also a
[Applause]
southerner
there's only two things i like shooting
commies and k-pop
self-sell sell sell
my favorite direction man thanks for so
much awesome stuff
i love sex you know sex is pretty cool
but uh 99 percent of my sex career was
so low and now i have to have an orgasm
while someone's fogging up my glasses
what the [ __ ] lady i know what my name
is
where's my office chair i gotta come
better watch porn
[Applause]
my name is hans kim that's my real name
it's a german korean name
it means i eat bratwurst but only if
they're made out of pimples
it means i hate japanese people but only
if they're jewish
arrogant and rich the worst
my parents sent me hans because they
didn't want kids at school to make fun
of me for having an asian name
so they gave me a german one instead and
i flew right under the radar
they didn't see the full-blown asian on
my face
really great-planned parents
yeah that's my real name uh i think i
have a funny name but i think it's even
funnier that
tanner is a white person's name
tanner than what you white [ __ ]
should be like hey this is my mexican
friend tanner that's my black friend
tanist
[Applause]
yeah i uh i grew up biologically
male but my bullies identified me as a
[ __ ] very gender fluid
i do not consent to this gender
i petition thee a lot of my boys were
like yeah you're both smart but i'm
street smart
oh you're smart in a way that's not
measurable or comparable
how convenient for you
maybe you're insecure about your
intellect and that's why you commit
aggravated assault
that's called crime stop touching me
it hurts
but uh i took up uh brazilian jiu jitsu
to defend myself
brazilian jiu jitsu is like normal jiu
jitsu except you try to shave your
opponent's pivot hairs off
they look ridiculous when you win on
social points
but uh i i am single i get to be my soul
mate i begin to think maybe it's her
fault she needs to get out more
she seems like a loser i think i can do
better
my friends are like dude you need to
learn how to talk to women maybe or
maybe women should learn how to listen
to hans
why don't you want to hear about
minecraft
we're at a party [ __ ]
i love the ladies i think they are the
sexiest gender in the human race
definitely in the top 35.
one of the best genders i don't think i
could ever have sex with a dude
sorry sir
i never looked at a beautiful woman i've
been like wow she's gorgeous but is
there a version of her that's bigger and
hairier and has less kindness
i want to put that in my butthole
never happened straight as [ __ ] please
believe me my dad doesn't
my dad's like dude we're so lucky we're
not gay can you imagine if most of the
gender we were attracted to wasn't
attracted to us back
i was like whoa can't even imagine
they must cry a lot
all the ladies what are you gonna do
with them um i don't understand why uh
women will say weird [ __ ] to me they're
like did you know that my vagina is
technically
can make a baby so it's a 3d printer
it's like your womb is a 3d printer your
vagina is the tray
[Applause]
it only prints one thing with lots of
errors
[Applause]
it takes nine months to print
and the whole time this printing is
complaining
needless to say i did not say any trace
out of you
but uh i'm a sapiosexual that means i'm
looking for a girlfriend who is
intellectually stimulated by the mental
exercise of finding me attractive
like a woman is into puzzles
you're wearing that tonight okay i can
drink it this house
[Music]
um i it's hard it's hard being an asian
man especially around asian women you
know because they act like they're so
much hotter than asian men but [ __ ] we
look exactly the same
i could throw on a wig and be a seven
[Applause]
why are you bragging that you can find
white dudes i get fun white dudes
[Applause]
people always think asian women are
hotter than asian men but how do you
think asian women are created
me [ __ ] i'm a crucial part of the
sexy process
please stop trying to skip me if you
have sex with me our children will be
very beautiful
half of them the other half will be
great engineers and that's important
but uh i am not a homophobe you know i
don't understand why people say adam and
eve not adam and steve because adam and
eve were not even a good couple
biblically
first of all they disobeyed god and they
ate a fruit they weren't supposed to eat
which is
kind of gay and then they raised cain
and abel and cain murdered abel
why are we taking a parenting advice
from people raising a murderer
there are only three other people on
earth become the core of the world's
population
[ __ ] psychopath but my sister is very
christian
she just got back from a mission trip uh
mission trip is when americans go to
their world countries to get new profile
pictures
[Applause]
um we grew up christian as asian people
which is kind of weird because the
people wrote the bible
didn't even seem to know that asians
existed
i couldn't even drop us the line
asians great job on the fireworks and
the great wall of china is really
present
back to the jews my favorites
[Applause]
all jews the whole [ __ ] thing is
about the goddamn cheese
this is great i deserve it
but um you know i'm not a racist i mean
i'm a minority how could i be
impossible i don't even see race i only
smell it
but um you know i was i was on an
airplane and i saw a dude reading a book
in arabic which kind of freaked me out
but then i saw hold the corner of the
page and put the book away and i was
like oh thank god he's got future plans
that's close my favorite marvel movie
would have to be the black panther movie
because he gave five children a hero
they can finally
look up to and not just someone like
martin king jr malcolm x or harriet
tubman or derek and marshall george
harper the boys
now there's a fake person that dresses
like a cat
[Applause]
congratulations
i'm just jealous what are they gonna
come out with a yellow panda huh
i'm gonna eat your furniture
yeah i love being asian or does it know
this country chinese
i'm from a province in china called
south korea
right next to japan province um
a lot of people when they meet me they
uh say hurtful things to me this one
goes like hey you're not really an asian
smile
i was like oh thanks now i get to think
about how i'm physically different from
everyone around me
every time i feel happiness
it's a microaggression but uh
whenever i go to starbucks i always tell
them that my name is ching chong bing
bong the third
so lika is like that's not your name
excuse me sir i come from a long line of
proud big bombs
what are you a ding dong
or he plays ping-pong
um you know a lot of people are racist
asians which i don't even [ __ ] mind
dude
you hate respectful people who keep to
themselves
okay good luck finding an affordable car
but trying really hard a lot of my asian
friends make fun of me because
i like to eat generous chicken like han
says in general says chicken just a
shitty
americanized version of something
authentically asian i was like yeah but
so am i
my favorite movie is rush hour 3.
[Applause]
i i get a lot of flack from people
asking me why asians eat dogs a lot of
people here
at the vulcan have asked me that
especially in upper management
let's get that rumor started but i
understand why it's shocking because in
america
dogs are treated like family members but
in asia we treat our family members like
family members
this is real a tradition we have back
home where uh instead of buying an
animal we just love our grandma
treat everyone better in asia unless
you're a baby girl in case you throw you
in the river
i look at the river um i think
it's funny that you know a lot of people
ask me why asians eat dogs it's because
they have bigger necks of us and
they're kind of driving and so we eat
them to consume their power to see
peripherally
all right that's what i said
[Applause]